faire en Ukraine puisque ça bouge à
Carson dans le sud ville contrôlé par
les russes depuis le début de la guerre
le ministre de la Défense vient de
prendre la parole à Moscou et il leur
donne le retrait des forces russes de la
rive droite du Nièvre Gulliver crag on
vous retrouve à carquif d'abord que
sait-on à propos de ce retrait est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer un piège pour les
Ukrainiens
certainement les Ukrainiens pensent à la
possibilité que ce soit un piège ça
c'est la première chose à dire on
devrait peut-être clarifier aussi que la
rive droite c'est la rive nord-ouest du
niepre et c'est sur cette rive là que se
situe la ville de Herson donc la
capitale régionale et il y a une partie
mais c'est la plus petite partie de la
région en termes de territoire les
Russes si il faut en croire les mots de
Serge shoyu en maintenant l'intention de
se retirer de cette partie là de la
région de Herson mais de continuer à
défendre la rive gauche donc la partie
sud-est j'ai discuté rapidement avec
nathalieu que la porte-parole pour les
forces armées de l'Ukraine dans le sud
du pays qui m'a dit les Russes ils
montent toujours et on ne peut pas du
tout prendre leur déclaration pour
argent comptant pour nous en fait ils ne
font que polluer l'espace informationnel
alors qu'on est toujours en train
d'essayer de maintenir le silence
informationnel sur sur le progrès de la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne mais dans les faits à part
la déclaration de ces goût ce qu'on a
observé aujourd'hui c'est l'explosion de
plusieurs ponts sur cette rive droite
dans la région derrière son a plusieurs
endroits un pont sur le net et plusieurs
ponts sur d'autres rivières et canaux il
faut croire que si les Russes font
exploser les ponts c'est bien que il
quitte les lieux et ne veulent pas que
les ukrainiens et l'utilité de ces ponts
en tout cas c'est peut-être la
conclusion simpliste mais ça me paraît
la conclusion la plus évidente à tirer
donc certainement en tout cas
un élément d'évidence qu'il serait
effectivement en train de se retirer
mais peut-être pour défendre la ville de
Herson autrement sous forme de cœur
partisane on a eu beaucoup
d'informations de rumeurs dernièrement
sortant de la ville de Herson comme quoi
des soldats russes seraient habillés en
civil et commencerait à s'installer dans
les maisons pour peut-être mener une
lutte partisan contre l'armée
ukrainienne une fois qu'elle arriverait
dans la ville voilà pour les
explications à Kerson Gulliver je
profite de votre présence dans la grande
ville de Quercy pour savoir ce qu'il s'y
passe
alors je suis venu à harkis en fait pour
aller dans la partie de la région de
harkif qui avait été occupé pendant de
longs mois puis libérer il y a environ
deux mois et la première ville
importante à être libéré c'était pas la
cliente je suis allé là-bas aujourd'hui
et d'un côté il y a une activité
impressionnante de reconstruction
vraiment ou que on regarde on a
l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose qui
est en train d'être réparé et un
enthousiasme et une énergie pour essayer
d'effectuer ses réparations avant
l'hiver notamment pour assurer qu'il y
ait du chauffage dans la ville mais
parmi la population ce qui était là
surtout pendant l'Occupation il y a des
histoires terribles que beaucoup de gens
ont très envie de raconter en réalité
dès qu'il voit avec la caméra ils
viennent ils ont envie de raconter comme
eux ou un membre de leur famille ou un
autre proche a été détenu par les Russes
et dont la plupart des cas j'ai
l'impression les gens qui ont été
détenus ont été servi sévèrement battus
et su à d'autres formes de torture qui
sont vraiment assez perturbants à
entendre donc c'est vraiment une
population qui est très perturbée par ce
qui s'est passé qui essaye de se
reconstruire eux-mêmes tout en
reconstruisant la ville autour de merci
beaucoup Gulliver crack pour votre
compte-rendu depuis qu'il